from the guy who brought you batman and
the green goblin in the lighthouse comes
the northmen a movie filled with so much
throat singing i thought i was at a
mongolian metal concert
this epic two-hour tale based off
scandinavian legend would actually
become the basis for shakespeare's
hamlet both tales containing revenge
murder and the supernatural so in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the northmen it's ending and some of the
details you may have missed along the
way and be sure to like and subscribe
the gods demand it the first shot is of
a real icelandic volcano mount hekla
literally translated it means gates of
hell and as we'll see throughout the
film it becomes more and more active
paralleling our main character's journey
of revenge and the movie's narration
flat out tells us what will happen that
a prince destined for valhalla will seek
revenge this transitions us to shots of
ravens in a snowstorm an apt image
considering amla's father king orvindil
is also known as the war raven the
ominous weather foreshadows the king's
eventual death and ravens become a sort
of guide for amleth along his journey
ravens are also what the norse god odin
used to bring him information so every
time they're on screen you could say
that odin is watching eagerly
anticipating his father's arrival is
young amleth who lives this sort of
fairy tale life with his noble father
adoring mother and loyal kingdom when
the king arrives you get the sense that
he's a loved and respected king the
people kneel before him and offer him
gifts but there's someone who doesn't
join the king on his victorious ride
from battle into town his brother
fionier at the welcome celebration the
king gives in with a necklace taken off
the dead body of a rival prince's neck
he will wear this into adulthood as a
reminder of his father it's kind of
ironic it's taken off a dead princess
amleth will also become a dead prince
but we'll get into that in a bit the
first inkling that this fairy tale life
isn't what it seems occurs when jaimer
the fool makes an off-color joke about
queen kudrin getting men hard now the
king doesn't really care that's what the
fool is supposed to do but it's fuel
near who defends the queen's honor when
we get to one of the big reveals later
in the film this scene will make a lot
more sense the king is dying having
sustained a wound to the liver that is
slowly killing him so he takes his son
to undergo a mystical ritual to prepare
him for adulthood there he inhabits the
qualities of a wolf something primal and
raw that will become part of his persona
throughout the film it's here amleth
must pledge to safeguard his family and
should his father die in battle avenge
him amleth cries and his tear is
collected by the fool saying it will be
the last tier he sheds until he needs it
this tier will later be given back to
him as an adult by the cirrus it's also
here that we get our first look of
yggdrasil the cosmic tree that serves as
the connection between the nine worlds
in norse mythology in the north minute
also serves as a literal family tree
showing the rightful rulers of amla's
bloodline but amla's reunion with his
father is short-lived because as they
emerge from their ritual his father is
shot by arrows the assailant his brother
fjolnier it's a brutal coup that sees
amleth fight for his life cutting off
the nose of one of his attackers who
will eventually tell the new king that
young amleth was killed from this point
on amleth vows to save his mother avenge
his father and retake his kingdom fast
forward several years an aimless vow
well it's gone by the wayside he's
turned into an emotionless animalistic
berserker who carries out bloody raids
to amassed slaves for warring kingdoms
he seemed to have forgotten what fate
has in store for him however that's all
to change when asiris of course played
by bjork returns to him the last tear he
shed reminding him of his vow and that
the gods have a fate plan for him the
cirrus tells him that he will get his
revenge atop a mountain filled with fire
and that a maiden king will spring from
his ashes it's all pretty cryptic and
amleth doesn't really know where to go
until he hears that fuel near lost much
of his kingdom and fled to iceland and
where are those slaves they just got
headed iceland of course so he cuts his
hair and brands his chest disguising
himself as a slave to get closer to his
murderous uncle it's here he meets olga
of the birch forest who will become
amless ally and lover together they join
forces to take down fuel near however
when amla is able to gain access to the
king's quarters he makes a shocking
discovery that his mother is now married
to his uncle amleth sneaks off into the
night where ravens guide him to a
he-witch this dude holds the rotting
head of the fool who was beheaded by
fjondir probably for that sexual comment
he made about the queen there he learns
where he must find the weapon the gods
want him to exact his revenge with and
in order to acquire it he must kill the
mound dweller an undead sword wielder
who seems to be derived from the old
norse draugrs the dead who watch over
tombs the draugar is thought to be an
early type of vampire which may explain
its vulnerability to moonlight and how
it holds a sword that can only be
unsheathed at night or at the gates of
hell regardless amleth fells the
creature but knows he can't kill fuel
near just yet fate has told him that he
will kill his uncle among a lake of fire
and there's none of that in the village
so amlath bides his time doing whatever
he can to make life for the king and his
men a living hell this includes a brutal
scene in which amleth chops up a bunch
of the king's men and nails them to a
longhouse an act which the king surmises
may be the work of christians since
their god was nailed in a similar
fashion amlath gains special privileges
when he saves the king's son during a
game of nataliker basically an old
viking game using paddles that looks a
bit similar to lacrosse bonus points if
you caught that the huge opponent on the
other team was played by the mountain
from game of thrones who also happens to
be icelandic amlath and olga devise a
plan to poison the guards allowing amlet
to rescue his mother but he finds out
that his mother never loved his father
not only that he finds out that he
wasn't the son of a loving marriage like
he always thought but that his father
took his mother as a slave bride and
forced himself upon her he is not the
child of love but of rape all this time
it was the queen who begged fuelner to
kill his own brother and take over the
throne so the two of them could be
together now that event where the fool
made fun of the queen and the king not
protecting her honor while fjallnir did
makes a little more sense but amleth
tells her he saw her screaming that day
his father was killed but she says those
were laughs is this to be believed or
are we merely hearing the words of a mad
woman who has concocted this history in
her mind to justify her actions and
things get even weirder when the queen
makes a move on her own son and the two
kiss this is a woman who had to endure
god knows what and will do whatever it
takes to survive in this unforgiving
place and time she's also incredibly
unhinged so while i found this totally
gross i didn't think it was that
unbelievable all of this is a betrayal
for amleth but as he tells olga he will
not kill a woman let alone his own
mother with his true identity revealed
he must hide in the surrounding hills
and it's only when fiona is about to
kill olga for not giving up information
about amleth that he comes back and
risks his own life to save her this is
the first time that amleth does
something for someone other than himself
you may have noticed that the fight
scene in which he takes on the king's
men takes place with an entirely
sheathed sword that's because it's
daylight and the blade will not come out
in sunlight kind of like me in high
school during a world of warcraft raid
amleth is captured but his confinement
and torture is short-lived as ravens
peck away at his bonds allowing him to
escape it's a real example of deus ex
machina or should i say odin x machina
where an outside force is manipulating
the plot it's olga who actually comes
back for him and knocked out from his
torture amleth believes he's being
ridden away on horseback by a valkyrie
to the gates of valhalla now this could
just be me i did this while taking notes
in a dark movie theater but during the
early fort raid scene there's one shot
where you can see a blonde-haired woman
on horseback with a red cape who kind of
looks like this valkyrie in the
background she even says she wants quote
the strong ones since valkyries only
allow strong warriors into valhalla am i
completely crazy or did any of you see
this as well amleth decides to forgo his
vow of vengeance and leave iceland with
olga but as they leave he finds out olga
is pregnant with two children his of
course the fate he was told said from
his ashes would spring a maiden king and
that he would have to choose between
kindness for his kin and hatred for his
enemies if he left iceland he would be
turning away from this fate the gods had
threat for him so he jumps ship and
leaves olga he believes this to be both
a kindness to her and his children
knowing she would have gone with him and
likely died in the process and a hatred
for his enemies since he'll wind up
avenging his father amleth causes chaos
at the king's camp by lighting
everything on fire and freeing the
slaves and in a twisted set of events
he's forced to kill his mother and half
brother after they surprise attack him
fionnier comes across amleth in front of
the bodies of the queen and prince and
instead of fighting him right then and
there agrees to battle at the gates of
hell that mountain we saw at the
beginning of the film which has started
to erupt this also allows fjallner to
prepare a crude viking burial for his
wife and child where a horse is buried
alongside the dead to carry them to
valhalla as fate predicted amleth fights
his uncle beside a fiery lake of lava
along the mountain's edge you can even
hear amleth chanting before the battle
that he will cut the thread of fate by
him killing his uncle he will be free of
it the fight culminates in fuel near
decapitated and amleth receiving a sword
through the chest amleth has achieved
his revenge but in so doing has brought
upon his own death just like fate
predicted as he dies he sees visions of
olga holding their two children knowing
they are safe and his bloodline intact
with his final breath we can see a glint
in his eyes the reflection of him being
led into the gates of valhalla by the
valkyrie he has fulfilled his fate and
avenged his father even though he died
doing so just like hamlet is a tragedy
so too is the northman it shows how one
man's lust for revenge results in the
countless pain and deaths of others but
on the other hand you get annie taylor
joy as your lover so it all evens out
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember
you